This is for thinking people.
who does not want to think better turn off immediately
Ladies and gentlemen
This is the difference between left and right.
No one is dealing with this theater.
set around the table
Actually Magdalence
Where is one party
So at the moment the post pretends to be conservatives
and the second there after pretending minerals
This is of course theater.
This is not a right hand.
These are all socialists.
And the center of the left said
Here is the right
State sitting
at a meeting with a representative
a right-wing party and a reactionary
to say it clearly and openly
for every action
comes reaction and to the madness of the left
There is a reaction and it is our move.
This is a reactionary movement
movement movement
who wants to restore normality